Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Five Nights at Freddy's
Help Wanted
Okay so, what I'm gonna do now...
Is vent repair.
Now there's only two levels that I can see.
And I'm pretty sure I can count to two.
One.
And the other number that I don't know.
So, this one says Mangle.
I'm not sure what it means to do vent repair.
"Grab and release and pull trigger"-
But it probably has something to do with the similarity to...
Eugh.
I keep thinking there's something over here...
Also, this mud and or fecal matter is not *inhale* very reassuring.
But it says "Vent Repair Mangle." so I don't know, but we're gonna find out.
Oh, that's- ch too close to my face
Oh, that's- Uh, OH
Oh, wait a minute.
Hang on a second.
-Nervous laugh-
Oh surely they must be joking.
Oh surely, SURELY they must be telling the jokes here.
Surely they must be saying the jokes-  That looks like Squidward.
Okay, alright I'm an idiot but here we go.
I don't like it.
Uh huh.
Wooow.
Oh.
OH
*confused mark noises*
OH COME ON
I know-
I KNEW YOU WERE GONNA DO THAT!!!
Ha-  It's the oldest trick in the book-
Okay, uhm-
HUEH! WHOA! OKAY!
Whoa! WHOA! WHOOOA!
WHOOOOOOOOOOOOA
-DEUHNDAB-. WHAT AM I DOING!?!?!?
Hoo, HOO
hohohhohohohohohohohohoho
HOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
HO THEY MUST BE JOKING
OH THEY MUST
OH JOKING THEY MUST BE
Oh they must- OHHA
Oh.
OH
THEY MUST BE JOKING
OH THEY MUST
THEY ARE TELLING ALL OF THE JOKES
OHH
wh-WHERE!?
WHA'S HAPPENING
WHA'S HAPPENING!?!?
OH- HEY!!! HEY!! HEY!!!!
WHAT THE FUCKING-
HOOooooly crAP- Okay
Alright
Uuuuuuuuuuugh
Youyouyouyouyouyou
HEY
WHERE
AAAAA
I hear yah, Squidward, you peein' on me.
Okay, HEY!
Oohh- Frick.
Oh frick
HOOH
WHOA
HOH
Okay, alright
Huh, HOH
HOH
OH THEY MUST
WHOA THEY MUST BE JOKING- Oh -Screaming-
OH- FUCKING GOD
OH FUCK ME
Ookay, uh, Blue, Green -out of breath mark-
eeeuh okay blue green
WHA? wha okay what is it-
Blue- GODDAMMIT
-Screaming- WHO!? WHERE!?
Ooh fuck me-
Red, Ye- Red orange blue green
red, orange, blue, green- WHOOAHH
OH HOOH
OH- PUT IT UP, PUTTITU- WAH AHH
WAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHH
-panting-
-continues panting-
-catches breath-
I'm sorry, for what was probably the most spastic gameplay footage you've ever seen in your life.
What I am not sorry for-
Is the amount of poop in my pants.
I'm not sorry for that in the least.
OOOOOOOOOOH LOOK AT YOOOU
Aren't you just the sweetest thing
You wouldn't mind if I rip yer eye out would ya?
Doll: "No please! Dont do the"---MARK NOISES---
"AHHHHHHH"
"I won't look at you cause my eye's been ripped out"
M: Obviously it has, finally a good ol' finishing punch to the back o' the nog, "NOO! ANYTHING BUT-" BOINK
And you're ded.
Okay, so, let's go back to the most horrifying thing I've ever do- oohhhh
Am I readin' that right?
Is the VR messin' with mah eyeballs or does that say ENNARD on it
An' if it says ENNARD.
Whadoes that mean for me
Sister location favori-
woof(..?)
Oh- Ohh- SURELY you must be joshin'.
You must be doin' the joke tellin' I've heard so much about
You MuSt be
Be reciting those HILARIOUS jokes
The likes of which have only been told in rumors and legends
SURELY -Nervous laughter-
God
Oh- WHY AM I IN A BOX!?!?
I'M IN A BOOOX
I'm gonna die- I'mgonnaDIE
I HATE IT
I'MGONNADIE
Here we go
Great.
Uh oh.
Uh huh.
Wha- HEY-WHOAWHOAWHWHOA
I'm- BUH
BUHUH
BUHUHUH
I thought that was where I was gonna be doing the things
An' the stuff-
[upbeat music starts]
Oh- OH- OH- HOOOH
HOOH
HOOH- Oh- Okay, alright, well-
WHADDOESTHATMEAN
HOOooh
Okay
Hello- aH- AH
hAH-aH
Haah- I don' trust
Okay, okay- HAAH
AAAH, WHADDO I HEAR
WHADDO I HEAR!?
I hear something, oh god I hear something- ookay
Uhm-
Okay, green. GOT IT! OKAY!
Whaaeh- okay
Oh fffffffff
Fuck me
Whaddisthat
They're all wrong-
THEY'RE ALL WRONG!
Why are they all wrong?
Oh- there we go
What the fuck
What the fuck?
Wait- I don' get it
Whaddam I missing here?
Whaddam I missing?
Okay- there we go
We got somethin'
OH
wait-
is it the corresponding light that goes-
okay so that one goes to that one
this light goes to this one
Ah, I get it
it was just the wires, I wasn't paying attention-
I wasn't paying attention... obviously
oKaY
AlRiGhT
AH
AH-WHOA -gibberish- WAIT WAIT WHADDO I DO
oh god- okay, you're there
ah- here- OHFUCC OH FUCK
AAAAAAAAAAAA
HAAH
HAAAH
Okay, alright
So it's gonna be like that, huh?
Okay.
That's fascinating that that is the way that that is.
Ehh, frick
Okay, so what I didn't realize.
Is that I just needed to follow the pattern
With the wires
I didn't reali-
I thought it was just guessing the pattern until it was right.
I didn't know that that was...
The thing that it was.
Okay... You go...
There...
You go there...
You're there and there.
Okay, alright. I got this, so I just can't make mista-
I'm probably on a time limit, but I just need to not make mistakes
I think that's what really gets him going
He's really sassy like that, okay you're much closer than I would've liked for you
WOAH HEY. Okay, you're gettin' here fast
Okay, um... You are down there.
Oh fuck me
That one, okay you are there...
Follow the wire. Follow the wire. Oh shit. Follow, what wire is that?
What wire is that?
Goes... What? Oh, there THERE THERE, right there and DAT BUTTON
-mark laughing in triumph-
-scared mark noises- WHA DO I DO?! WHA DO I DO?!
Oh no. No x4.
No x5. You- You- I- I- I should've been done!
That should've been it!
That was it right?!
*scared and upset mark noises*
Oh surely, this must be one of-- yet another of your hilarious GOOFS, GAFFS, and GUFFAWS
Oh, that doesn't look friendly
That doesn't look good at all
Oh boy.
Well... good to know that there's all these hilarious gears and gizmos, all the way down here.
[upbeat music starts up again]
Ohhh....
Okay, I'll take that, thank you.
[kids cheering]
Oh, there- there's that. Is there like a gear? Am I supposed to... Oh, what is this? Oh, yeah! Yeah, yeah! Um, yeah? Oh!
HEY! Oh, hi! Um, what do I do about you?
What do I do about you?
Um, hueh wait. Okay, I'll take this one and put it there. Okay! Alright, that's good, right?!
Hey, can I... Are you gonna be a problem?! Oh hi! Hello! How are you, what do I do about you?
Wha... What the fuck? Do I take? Hoh, hoh, okay. Oh shit, oh, oh go-, oh god. Oh, oh fuck me, oh, oh god.
OH, OH FUCK ME. OH HEY, WAIT A MINUTE, WAIT WAIT!
*scared and confused mark noises*
You, there. You ther- no! You there. Ohhh, fuck! I don't have anything that you need here!
I don't know what I need. Is there another gear, or something somewhere??
What do I do? Wha do I do? I don't know what I do!
I don't know what I do! I don't know what I do!
How are you there?! I just turn my head, and you're not there, and there's no thing there.
You're still there, I don't... get it!
I'm not, I'm running low on gears. I don't have enough, you're not doing anything, so I'm not 100% sure what I do about that!
Hello? Hello? Uah.
AH! Aw, fuck okay! I don't know man! I don't know!
I didn't have enough gears! Didn't have enough gears...
Didn't have enough gizmos, gears, gaffs, goofs. I didn't have enough
So this next one, it's just gotta be something about, like just gears! I just have to get gears, right? That's it! I think.
Eugh, I hate that...
Okay, so it's all gears... Oh, fuck! What the fuck was that?!
Wait what? Did you guys see that? There was something there!
Okay, if I die, which is almost guaranteed, um apparently there's uh, I think it was that- that Bonnie toy that Funtime Freddy has, sometimes.
[upbeat music starts]
What the fuck? Is that like a collectible that I can get? I have no idea.
Okay, oh wait! Oh, wait! Oh, you! That's what I need to do! Oh! I need this to keep going so that I can get... This!
This is gonna pump out, yeah! Yeah! This- this need- Oh, wait why is this not going? This should be going, right?
Do I need to...
Wait... Fucking, what the fuck?
But that's not going there, so I see what I need over there. So, this blocks that off but this doesn't cause that to go.
There's another one! Oh! I see, okay! I get it! I get it! I get it!
Hi! Okay, I get it! Hang on, a second! Hang on a second.
Okay, um get that out, put that there. Grab this, put that there. Put this here.
Uh, no no, there. No no, shit!
*overwhelmed markimoo*
FUCK! OH, FUCK! OH, OH FUCK!
Oh, fuck, no not the coin! Okay, uh fuck. Uh, no! This, here! Grab that, grab that! And there and there!
*relieved mark noises*
Oh, there's more...
Oh, of course, there's more. Okay, be on the lookout.
Everybody be kinda on the lookout, for anything that looks good.
That was the coin that I dropped but I already got that one so...
Oh, fuck
Okay, it's all good, it's all good. Okay, alright everybody stop panicking cause this is um...
This is manageable...
Oh, fuck...
Oh, fuck. Oh, hoh boy, why do I gotta go so far down? Why is this place so big? This is a rental shop!
[upbeat music starts]
Isn't it?
Oh, that doesn't look good...
Oh, that does not look good, okay um... Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Yeah, no joke. Okay, no joke. No joke about that. One, two, three, four.
What... Oh, fuck. Okay, ah... One, and so it's just this, it's very simple, easy I guess, done.
Okay, not a problem! It's dark, but not a problem!
Oh, boy. Alright, what is this, what the hell?
What the fuck is that about? Oh, god! Oh- Oh my god! Oh my god! Oh my god!
Okay um, okay two up there, then there but the, oh my god. Oh my god. Oh, oh I did it, I guess.
*scared mark laughing*
Oh, it's dark. Oh, it's dark.
Okay, hands is all I can see.
Oh, boy. Button? I trust button, I shouldn't trust button! Oh, fuck I don't trust button.
What do I do? Oh, shit! Oh, fuck! Oh, what, what?
*THUD*
[distorted screaming]
AH! HEY!
Wha?
[upbeat music]
What the fuck?!
Wha- eh What?! What did I do?!
What did I just do?
What, did- did I just burn...
Ennard?!
Did I burn...
Did I burn Ennard?
"All treats certified to be delicious no- though not always nutritious," okay.
[cRuNcH]
I think I burned Ennard, I think I burned Ennderd...
I burned Ennder. I burned- I burned. I burned Ennard.
I'm not gonna do it right now, but I just want to see what, what ah, what Nightmare vent repair.
*scared mark laughing*
So you get both of them, heh.
Everyone else you get one, oh wait no you don't, no you don't, no you don't
Nooo you don't. Oh my GOD!
Oh my go- Okay, alright well I'm, fuck that shit.
They must be joking, they must be doing the jokes on me, and I'm not one to do jokes!
Ah, I'm all joked out for now. So, next up is the final of the normal modes, Night Terrors
And then... well Night Terrors... we move on to... that thing,
Okay, so anyway but that's al- Thankfully, that's all the time I have for this one.
Thank you, everybody, so much for watching, uh hope you're enjoying this, I'm having a ton of fun.
So, thank you, everybody, so much for watchi- ohp.
So, thank you, everybody, so much for watching, let me know what you think in the comments below.
There's more Five Nights at Freddy's, all over my channel, I'll link in the description to all the other cool stuff,
and just thank you, everybody, so much for watching.
And as always, I will see you, in the next video.
Buh Bye!
[Outro song: Shirk - Haunted]